zach f what his 12th fall game two and
five at era of 4.10
hoping to replicate what he did against
the braves on the 7th of may when he
went six and two thirds that was the
last victory
for zach ronaldo cooney jr leads it off
tunia junior
six for 21 against effluent with a home
run
and a strike three called on the outside
corner he went with a slider to get a
curvy junior looking one out
here in the first front door slider
let's hope that is an indication of good
things to come
that was lovely kind of locks a cuny up
he thinks it's low it's right on the
line
what a way here's freddie freeman swag
it'll miss he threw him a change up but
he's got back-to-back strikeouts
all right so this is what we talked
about nothing's in the middle
of the plate no but it's in the strike
zone all these was over three last night
with a couple walks
of pitch blacks down the right field
line
and that'll be extra basis for all these
you just got to hope that it's not a
triple and it dies in the corner
and albies is around second on his way
to third and segura has no throw
it's a triple the fourth of the year for
all these
and he is in scoring position with two
outs
austin reilly he was three for five last
night with a couple rvis
and he lines one back toward the middle
a humpback liner right at segora
doesn't even have to move and the inning
is
no runs one hit tucker davidson trying
to extend the braves win streak to four
straight yeah you see two starts this
season good numbers across the board
still looking for his first win
as this one is cracked to left almante
on the run he's going to get there and
hopefully replaces divot
man he's lucky he didn't tear up a knee
yeah makes the rolling catch
out of the grass and left field think he
wanted to slide to that but caught a
spike in the grass went into a barrel
roll
and fortunately had it in the glove so
the braves rely on a couple of really
nice defensive plays to get him through
the bottom of the first inning that'll
bring heredia up with nobody out
and the bases loaded here in the second
a bouncer over to third balm's coming
home
and they get the force out at the plate
one and two the count effluent ready
here's the pitch
and it's right there for a called third
strike he did his job
acuna struck out looking his first time
up one and two is the count
base is loaded two down effland ready
the one-two pitch
so i'm going to bounce to third bombs
got it steps on third inning is over
nice and zack keflan able to get out of
trouble
no runs ahead by atlanta no score riley
lined out softly to segora off the hands
out towards second segura
makes the catch throws back to first
where was albie's going
i don't know if he was challenging him
or what but he's doubled up
that is not a good play and thankfully
the fills take advantage of it
double play on the line drive off the
bat of austin riley and phil he's
nothing in the braves nothing
freddie freeman is the batter with one
out and one on
back to the box that one's got uh oh
nice play by teres oh man
they'd say he was off the bag at second
they get one freddy freeman's out at
first and i think
replay will show in fact acuna junior is
already walking off the
the fields duranus immediately got up
and pointed to the dugout for them to
look
at it i don't know how he could not have
gotten the second base back
now they're gonna look at it that was an
unbelievable play
ball and glove foot is on bag i am not
sure what nick lentz is looking at
it shouldn't take long at least well he
wasn't looking at his foot that's why he
was looking at the ball in the gloves
because then he went back to look at the
foot this is a wonderful play
thereas just saved zac eflin
and the phillies in this inning wow
all right here we go joe west to your
left makes the call
joe putting a little emphasis into it
yeah they looked at both
that was emphasis yeah for him no runs
no hits a walk and nobody left
no score william contreras who's uh only
23
made his debut last year for atlanta the
1-1 pitch
is on the ground up the middle of base
hit here comes dansby around third he's
going to score the kid comes through
he's three for three atlanta's got him
first and third they break through in
the sixth inning it's one to nothing
what a series he's had offensively man
who says you can't score a run with four
singles in a modern game
unconventional but three straight base
hits after the double play
effort got the ground ball he wanted
ranger suarez will
come in he's got about sixth and
adrianza
is going to pinch in all right so both
uh starting pitchers bender out of this
ball game
swag and a miss change up that's an
outstanding pitch for suarez
and there's one out here in the seven
say that but he's also got a really good
fastball
what's the late movement you read
fastball fastball and then whoop
out of the zone nowacuna junior he
walked his last time over two in
tonight's game
out to right field harper's going back
he's got
room and he makes the catch
there are two outs here in the seventh
inning here's freddie freeman
and a call strike three he didn't go
inside he went right down the middle of
the plate
and it's a one two three seventh inning
brains will turn this one nothing lead
over to the bullpen and the first guy
out is tyler matsek
his last outing was last night he worked
two thirds of an inning gave up a hit
and a walk
but no runs first guy he will face is
luke williams the rookie
the pitch breaking ball he chased it up
and out of the zone that's five
strikeouts for the phillies offense
tonight and that's it has his first of
tonight's
relief appearance one away yeah it was a
hanger but
as we say hung it higher than i can't do
anything with it
matching ball on a black glove even with
the letters 02.
chopper out there to short dan's we've
got it on a couple of twin hops
goes over to freddie freeman two down
one two on the way
he swings at a ball in the dirt and
strikes out good inning out of matsic
a one two three frame with a couple of
strikeouts will head to the top of the
eighth inning
where the braves on top of the phillies
one to nothing outside of that walk two
strikeouts by harper
erin harper swings through 94 miles an
hour
14 straight phillies have been set down
by the brave staff
and we look for some ninth inning
insurance 26 games there in the season
for will 11 for 11 and save
opportunities
the 2-2 pitch strike three belt high
fastball
and hoskins is retired one out
and miller pops it up on the first pitch
thank you very much
after a walk and ozzie puts the squeeze
on that the braves are
out away and now it's the rookie luke
williams he's the final phillies hope
fly ball left field already is going
back toward the wall
it did creep into everybody's mind
it's a two-run walk-off home run
luke williams yes sir
how about this welcome to philadelphia
i think we know who we're going to
interview partner wow
what a reaction by his family what a
reaction by his teammates
what a reaction by luke williams
a 2-1 victory by the phils with a
two-run
walk-off here at the bottom of the ninth
inning
that was incredible